michel je vais commencer avec vous parce
que c'est évident et me cause beaucoup
d'inquiétude surtout auprès des femmes
enceintes mais cette déclaration de l'om
est ce aujourd'hui qu'est ce que ça
implique
mais c'est assez spécifique ça ne parle
pas comme tel 2 de la fièvre zika que
nous pouvons tous avoir qui n'est pas
mortel mais beaucoup plus les cas de
micro encéphalite chez les femmes en
scène qui vont donner naissance à des
enfants avec de tout petits tête ça il
ya des foyers actuellement au brésil et
on est inquiet que ça ça se propage
ailleurs dans le monde
alors ce que cette annonce là vont nous
donner ces des moyens tout d'abord de
vérifier s'il ya vraiment un lien entre
ces micro à ces familles là et le virus
zika parce que ça c'est pas très clair
on va partir
les études épidémiologiques pour le
montrer on a pas de vaccin alors on va
travailler à un vaccin peut être d'ici à
la fin de l'année et ou si on va tenter
de regrouper les efforts des pays pour
la prévention pour la fumigation et
aussi peut-être pour des traitements
possibles pour ces gens là alors
évidemment on le disait c'est le brésil
qui est le plus touché là dedans et pour
les autorités c'est extrêmement
difficile de faire face à cette rupture
n'est admis aujourd'hui que c'était
beaucoup plus grave que ce qu'on pensait
on sait pas combien de personnes ont été
infectées 500 milles 1 millions trois
millions cinq c'est pas clair sur les
canaux de microcéphalie on parle de 3700
peut-être il ya deux cent mille soldats
qui ont été déployées on veut éradiquer
le moustique on parle de décès de
manipulations génétiques ans dans les
mâles stériles infecter les cinématiques
femelles pour les décourager de piquer
par exemple on essaye tous notamment les
tests de dépistage on travaille là
dessus on parle d'un sérum aussi pour
traiter ceux qui sont qui sont atteints
c'est une troisième play pour le pays en
grave récession
avec en plus des scandales de corruption
très très sévère et là bon
le virus a été introduit pour la coupe
du monde là on parle de jeux olympiques
cette année ça pourrait être aussi assez
catastrophique d'autant plus que le
gouvernement brésilien a découragé et
demande aux femmes qui sont anciens de
ne pas se rendre aux jeux olympiques
alors on craint évidemment des
annulations
le cio est en contact avec les autorités
brésiliennes va faire des
recommandations aux délégations pour les
athlètes bien sûr ceci dit en août ce
sera l'hiver brésilien moins chaud plus
sec donc ça risque de s'atténuer
évidemment bon au total 24 pays sont
touchés il est plus touché après c'est
la colombie on parle de 20 mille cas le
venezuela à peu près pareil le mexique
beaucoup moins touchés c'est l'hiver
là-bas il fait pas encore très chaud
c'est sec faudra voir après mois d'avril
vous les femmes enceintes au brésil mais
là le gouvernement recommande carrément
aux femmes de reporter leur grossesse
via d'autres pays qu'ils font aussi et
tous hors relance un débat très
difficile là au brésil suivi sur
l'avortement oui et tout à fait à leur
éviter de tomber enceinte dans les
deuxième neuf années à venir c'est la
consigne bon pratiquement c'est dans des
pays où il n'ya pas de contrôle des
naissances c'est irréaliste
il ya beaucoup de femmes qui tombent
enceintes aussi suite à des violences
sexuelles l'avortement est interdit à
peu près partout sauf en uruguay a qu à
cuba ou williana et dans la ville de
mexico un petit peu plus tolérés au
chili au brésil
c'est illégal sauf en cas de viol au
salvador imaginez on peut risque une
peine de prison qui peut aller de 2 à 8
ans donc les ong qui s'occupe justement
cliquez sur la demande qui ont un petit
peu plus de tolérance et qu'on prévoit
des zones d avortement possible pour des
des femmes enceintes qui seraient
affectés par ce bon michel évidemment on
se souvient tous que l'on aimait cette
mobilisation mondiale de la santé avait
été très critiqué au moment de
l'épidémie d'ebola là il ya des
questions qui se posent sur la rapidité
de cette réaction aujourd'hui est ce
qu'on peut penser que ça a été
influencée peut-être par ces critiques
il ya deux ans oui beaucoup céline je
crois qu'il ya beaucoup de ça parce
qu'on apprend beaucoup de chiffres
fiables pour arriver à faire un lien
entre ce virus là et les micros sa
encéphale y regardons un peu des
statistiques que j'ai obtenu du
ministère de la santé du brésil on va
regarder les chiffres
3400 cas suspectés de microcéphalie on
se retrouve actuellement avec 270 cas
confirmés selon gouvernement et
seulement 6 céline dans lesquels on peut
faire un lien entre la présence du virus
est là microcéphalie donc on est encore
loin des chiffres alarmants pour
l'instant alors on a de la difficulté
difficultés parce qu'on fait du
surdiagnostic on voit digne de 4000 à
270 le diagnostic est difficile à faire
et il ya aussi le fameux gebhard et qui
est cette maladie neurologique est aussi
qu'on prétend que c'est lié c'est une
maladie qui paralyse soit de façon
partielle complète ou à court terme au
long terme
et là on n'a pas de chiffres fiables on
lance en l'air et pour l'instant
j'espère que cette annonce je louais
metz va donner l'argent et des moyens
pour aller confirmer si oui ou non il ya
un impact
merci beaucoup à vous deux pour votre
contribution au moins ça s'est un peu
plus clair oui j'ai servi